the biggest event in a decade but is
that because right now you can't buy
packages you can't just buy the whole of
the NBA final theories for example yeah
I mean the audience is is huge for live
sports I mean the way the TV landscape
is right now where more and more people
are watching shows on demand the fact
that you you know a network like ABC
could have all of the NBA Finals and get
this huge live audience that's good for
ratings and that also means it's very
good for advertising dollars as well
helped it was a seven game series
there's a 3-1 comeback as well yeah I
mean certainly the fact that you've got
you know LeBron James and Steph Curry
being just such famous athletes I think
only helped the ratings put it in
context for us an ad for something like
the final game for the NBA it relative
to a Super Bowl ad and we know we
talking multiples the Super Bowl I mean
yeah well I mean I think the Super Bowl
ads are always gonna be the most
expensive ads you can possibly get but I
mean you know a live audience I mean I
think the final numbers for last night's
game or close to about 30 million people
I mean that's almost you know a fifth of
television households so that's a huge
audience of advertisers are gonna pay a
premium to get in front of that that
audience our network's position
themselves to carry more events like
this one I know NBC is gearing up they
always seem to be gearing up for the
next Olympics they have such a long term
contract here but Comcast NBC are really
putting a lot of chips on the the
upcoming Summer Olympics yeah I mean
Comcast paid you know several billion
dollars for the rights to get the
Olympics all the way until 2032 who
knows what we'll be watching on TV then
but yeah I mean TV networks are really
trying to outbid each other they're
spending more and more on on getting the
exclusive rights to broadcast these and
then they pass that on to the cable
providers and the cable providers and
satellite companies are actually
charging consumers more and consumers
are saying my bills going up maybe I
don't need cable so there's sort of this
vicious cycle going on right now and
live sports are sort of right in the
middle of it what about the x1 the box
is it getting a lot of people that
wouldn't necessarily be cable
subscribers yeah I mean Comcast is
saying that they've
this technology now where yes you know
cable is expensive but they're gonna try
and give you a lot more for your money
and what they want to do is make it a
lot easier it's a search for a lot of
the programming that you you know you
have so for the Olympics there you can
search on Comcast Xfinity buy athlete by
country by event you can get alerts when
you know an American is about to win a
gold medal and you can actually search
it all through this voice controlled
remote that Comcast has and this is you
know technology that they're very proud
of and they're hoping is going to be as
you know as good as like the Amazon echo
or Apple Siri well if we keep pulling
out games like last night then I'm sure
it'll be a great success